welcome everyone i'm delighted to have
the chancellor here today uh chancellor
schultz that we've met before
but this first time i've been able to
host the white house
and uh
it's good to have a chance to get to
know you
personally
we're going to spend some time going
together
and you know state the obvious
germany is one of america's closest
allies
working on a lockstep further deter
russian aggression in europe
and address the challenges posed by
china
and for low stability in the western
balkans
we uh then we have to take on the
pandemic climate change and among many
of those issues we have a lot to talk
about
uh mr chancellor chancellor and uh
i'm looking forward to working closely
together uh with you and this year
during the germany's presidency of the
g7 looking forward to that as well so
welcome welcome welcome
floor is
yours thank you for having me here
really i appreciate it very much that we
have the chance to discuss all the
topics we raised they are very important
we are closest allies
intensely together and this is necessary
for
doing the
steps that we have to do
foreign aggression against ukraine so
it's an important meeting at a very very
important time
thank you all
[Applause]
thank you let's
let's go come on let's move
move please let's go thank you
thank you thank you let's go
thank you very much thank you